[Music]
on this sunday night
the race between vaccines and variants
the parents are going to win every time
the spring surge of cases just as more
vaccines
arrive the stabbing rampage at a library
in bc
leaves one woman dead halifax police
launch an internal investigation
after this attempted arrest is caught on
tape and canada's apology to an
all-black unit that served in the first
world war
global national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us canada is preparing for a ramp up of
vaccine deliveries
1.2 million doses of pfizer biontech are
arriving tonight
that's just the beginning of an
accelerated vaccination campaign
just a few weeks ago delays from the
pharmaceutical companies
put canada's inoculation drive on pause
but with cases rising in canada the need
for a more
rapid rollout is greater than ever
travis dunroj has our top story tonight
right across the country it's a race
between vaccines and variants
canada's chief public health officer dr
teresa tam
warned measures need to be stronger and
sustained longer
to control the spread of covet 19
variants highly contagious variants
significantly increase the threat of
uncontrolled epidemic growth
they spread a little easier they cause
more explosive outbreaks
and now there's actually growing data
that demonstrates that unfortunately
they cause
more significant illness in ontario for
a fourth straight day new cases top
2000 and variants of concern account for
about 60 percent of all new covet 19
infections in the province ontario is
moving two regions
into its highest level of restrictions
but there is growing concern measures in
those areas
including hamilton toronto and peel are
not strong enough
now it's dangerous plain dangerous
because these
these covet variants are escalating at
the time that i don't think
the province the political layers of the
province
really understand what they're what
they're dealing with
ontario is racing to get shots into arms
with nearly two million doses
already administered some hospitals in
the province created standby lists for
those under 70
but were quickly overwhelmed by people
signing up many were taken down
in manitoba the province's nurses union
says even those vaccinated
need to take variance seriously this is
not a ticket to
take your mask off and go shopping this
is we still have to be incredibly
incredibly vigilant
spas and gyms are already open in some
areas of quebec
including in montreal as easter and
passover get underway
the province is easing restrictions to
allow up to 250 people
to gather in places of worship so people
come in
they keep the safeguards they pray and
then afterwards they leave by other
doors
so their safety is there modeling from
the quebec institute of public health
predicts variants will make up half of
new coven cases by april
and there is growing concern that could
happen right across the country
as more vaccines touch down experts
agree
this is not the time to let our
collective guard down travis danrash
global news
a memorial is growing outside a library
in bc
it's where an unfathomable crime took
place a man with a knife stabbed seven
people
at random a woman in her 20s was killed
the suspect 20-year-old yannick benda
ogo has been charged with murder
as andrea mcpherson reports he was known
to police
and we must put the names of the victims
on the front page of every newspaper
and not the name of the stabber
emotions run high as another bouquet is
added to the growing memorial outside
the plaza where seven people were
stabbed seemingly at random
during a terrifying attack on saturday
afternoon a woman in her 20s did not
survive
those who live in north vancouver's lynn
valley neighborhood say this could have
happened to anyone
we live literally right next door so
yeah but you know like we have
friends who work at the coffee shop what
happened yesterday just really rocks you
and it really makes you realize what's
what's important
the chaos erupted during a book sale at
a public library that's when witnesses
say the suspect began stabbing people
inside the building before moving on to
the street
i heard the yelling and as soon as
everybody started running i just
went everyone's running i'm running
there was another 25 year old woman with
multiple stab wounds in the face that we
were helping with somebody else was
already there
there's at least six victims that we can
count within a within a
50-foot radius so it was pretty
traumatic i'm
still kind of worried about it a suspect
was taken down by
officers nearby he is known to police
and had a criminal record but the motive
remains unclear
we believe we know the who the what the
where and the when
it is our job now to determine the why
officers still haven't spoken to all of
the victims who remain in hospital with
varying injuries the community's mayor
admits
it's hard to make sense of this tragedy
this is going to impact our whole
community but there's no question that
the family and loved ones of the victims
are going to be the most deeply impacted
and so our heart
thoughts are with you this as community
members do what they can to lean on one
another
at a distance during this difficult time
but i just wanted to show my support
and i'm really sorry about it all andrea
mcpherson
global news vancouver to a developing
story in ontario where police are
investigating the kidnapping of a
20-thrilled woman
early this morning police were called to
a home in brampton
they heard screams and found a man and
woman inside a vehicle
in the garage but the man managed to
drive away with the woman in the back
seat
the vehicle was later found about five
kilometers away
police say the victim is selena auk the
suspect
21-year-old kwame garwood is wanted on
multiple warrants
including first-degree murder
police in halifax have launched an
internal investigation
it began after video surfaced that shows
an officer pointing his firearm at a
black man
whose arms are raised above his head
it's what the officer
says that is disturbing to the black
community elizabeth mcsheffrey has the
latest
and a warning this video may be
disturbing to some viewers
this disturbing video has been viewed
tens of thousands of times since it
surfaced on saturday
in it a halifax regional police officer
can be seen
aiming his weapon at a black man and
allegedly making an
audible threat against his life
on march 26 officers responded to a
weapons call on wentworth drive
they arrested three people but police
say a fourth suspect ran away
i was gone gone in a statement police
chief dan kinsella says the officer
captured on camera has been placed on
administrative duties
pending a full investigation and the
language he appeared to have used
is unacceptable we recognize that any
such incident can be deeply damaging to
police-community relations
but some members of the african nova
scotian community
already distrustful of local police are
not
impressed with the response we're
investigating we take this seriously we
value our relationship with the black
community
that's i mean it's just copy and paste
from every single time
given the context that we're in the fact
that the
chief of police is not responding on
record
until a video comes out is an evidence
of a problem
it's been two years since the wartley
report found black people
in the halifax area were six times more
likely to be street checked by police
than white people
expanding a rift that has not yet been
healed the work that we're trying to do
in terms of building community trust for
the police
who by and large do a really good job
there's always the possibility that
something like this
could hamper that but that's why it has
to be investigated that's why we need to
get all the details
nova scotia's police watchdog the
serious incident response team
says it hasn't launched an investigation
because it hasn't received a referral or
complaint
and in order to investigate it would
need a statement from the man seen
fleeing in the video
elizabeth mcsheffrey global news halifax
there was a funeral in montreal today
for a 44-year-old woman who posted a
video criticizing how hospital staff
treated her
before her death the mother of three
claimed she was injected with penicillin
despite telling doctors and nurses
she was allergic to the drug as mike
armstrong reports quebec's coroner
is now investigating
[Music]
there were two emotions front and center
at the funeral of mere
muo sadness at the loss of the 44 year
old
immigrant from cameroon but also strong
frustration
at how she was lost we hope that
all the investigations are going to go
well and
fast jamuo went to this hospital in
logee quebec
march first she had a problem with the
hip although she'd be diagnosed with
lymphoma nine days later
but it was how she was treated in
between that has many demanding
answers
shot this video from her hospital bed
and posted it to facebook
in it she claims the staff is killing
her slowly
she says she told them she was allergic
to penicillin but that they gave it to
her
anyway and jamoa also complains about
being isolated their reports the
hospital was nervous she had
tuberculosis
in her video she says she's being hidden
and kept from her family
she begs to be moved to another hospital
that did happen
seven days after she was admitted but
she would die at the second hospital
just two days later
supporters have helped protests outside
the first hospital demanding
answers at the funeral many were wearing
justice for murray
t-shirts the funds collected will go to
support her children
we did not expect something like this to
happen now so the
family was really in shock now the
quebec coroner is investigating the
regional health board says it's also
looking at what happened
but the case does have many drawing
parallels to another
joyce chaquan filmed herself in hospital
last fall just prior to her death
in eshequan's video hospital staff can
be heard verbally abusing her
fault the focus on this day was mourning
but that may
change ndromo's family says when this
stage is over
they'll decide what comes next mike
armstrong global news
montreal in the u.s the two recent mass
shootings have renewed calls for
lawmakers to pass
stricter gun control laws the suspects
in both cases used weapons they had
purchased legally democrats are hoping
this is an opportunity to tighten
background checks
but republicans are vowing to protect
the second amendment
jennifer johnson looks at the new battle
lines being drawn
members of congress visiting the sites
of the atlanta area spa mass shooting
that left eight people dead
six asian american women as democrats
make another push for stricter gun
control laws
these are now scars upon our country
that joined the other scars of these
mass shootings and tragedies that we've
seen
some democrats believe they can get
enough republican votes to pass a bill
expanding background checks
the accused gunman in atlanta bought his
weapon the day of the shootings
after passing an instant background
check with no waiting period
don't count us out i think the politics
have shifted dramatically
since 2013 even since 2016 the last time
that we had a vote on background checks
the biden administration is urging
congress to pass stricter laws
to stop the epidemic of mass shootings
that has infected the u.s for decades
while most republicans are gearing up
for a fight others believe there is room
for compromise
you're not going to get to 60 votes with
legislation
that requires a when a father wants to
sell his
gun to his son to have to get a
background check i still think the best
way to do this is focus on
commercial sales not on the table yet
the much tougher fight to ban assault
weapons
the accused shooter who left 10 people
dead at a boulder grocery store
bought his assault weapon the week
before the rampage
gun control activists fear what happened
in atlanta and boulder is the new normal
after gun sales skyrocketed in 2020 the
busiest
year on record we know about 50 million
guns were sold
in the last year many of them to people
who live in states that don't require a
background check or training or
permitting
and so i'm truly afraid a group of
senate republicans will work
over the next several weeks to draft a
bill that has a chance of passing
encouraging any republican to work with
them
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up the mix and match strategy in
the uk why
experts are closely watching this
experiment
there's an urgency to speed up
vaccinations but
doses are in short supply so the world
is watching an experiment taking place
in the uk
scientists there have launched a trial
to see if it's safe
to mix and match vaccines that require
two shots
as crystal gramansing explains it's been
done successfully with other vaccines
the eyes of the world are once again
fixed on britain
after being the first western nation to
start a mass covet 19 vaccination
campaign
it's now testing a mix and match
strategy
820 trial participants are involved
some will get an astrozenica primer
followed by a pfizer biontech boost
others will have the opposite or
they could get two doses of the same
shot
the current standard practice dr alan
bernstein says the findings could change
how the world responds to the pandemic
we're getting really short of supplies
now you know there's just a limit how
many
vials or chemicals one can make in the
world to vaccinate the hundreds of
millions of people that have already
been vaccinated
and so as we we need to make sure
everybody on the planet is vaccinated
and that's going to require i think this
flexibility of supply
if the mix and match strategy addresses
that researchers say it would be a major
step
forward but it could also lead to
enhanced immunity
while all of the vaccines target the
spike protein
they focus on different locations in
that region
so mixing doses may possibly provide
broader spectrum immunity this is not a
crazy idea that suddenly just come up
because we're
so desperate for vaccines for covid this
is actually something that
immunologically makes sense
vaccines for ebola tb and malaria are
already based on the mix and match
concept
while widely used in other disease
treatments
the uk study is the only one underway
looking
at covid19 vaccines something that
surprises this saben vaccine institute
leader
like the rest of this response we want
this to be the best science-based
response as possible
and it'll be important to know if a
followed by b
is as good as a followed by a or vice
versa
i'm due to get my second shot my boost
in one or two months i hope
i hope the trial is done by the time
it's time for me to get my boost
and i can i can have that option or at
least talk to my physician
about which vaccine i should come in
with both dr bernstein
and barrett say there are conversations
about a similar trial
starting in canada results from the uk
trial
are expected this summer crystal
gomencing global news
london still ahead a deadly blast in
indonesia
just as holy week begins
just in case you were wondering that
ship in the suez canal
well it's moved but it's still stuck the
ever given did nudge a few degrees
saturday night but
that's about as far as it got it's now
on its sixth day blocking the vital
trade route
about 14 tugboats are still trying to
dislodge the ship but they don't seem to
be getting anywhere
over 300 ships are waiting on either
side of the canal to pass
causing a major disruption to the global
shipping network
myanmar's military isn't backing down
from its crackdown on protests despite
condemnation from around the world
[Music]
there are reports soldiers shot mourners
who gathered at a funeral for a student
killed yesterday
the bloodiest day of the coup at least
114 people died
including children protesters have
returned to the streets but there were
no large-scale demonstrations indonesia
is on edge tonight after a suicide
bombing during a palm sunday church
service
the blast happened just as mass was
ending on the first day of the easter
holy week
at least 20 people were hurt and taken
to hospital police say the two suspected
suicide bombers
died a security guard tried to stop them
from entering the grounds on a motorbike
indonesia's president condemned the
attack as an act of terrorism
up next how one american city is
addressing discriminatory housing
policies
[Music]
the canadian government is planning to
apologize to an all-black military unit
that served in the first world war the
number two construction battalion was
formed in 1916.
there were 600 men in the battalion half
of them were from nova scotia
they had volunteered to go to battle but
were turned away
because of the color of their skin but
they did build and maintain
critical infrastructure for canada's war
efforts in a virtual ceremony today
marking 104 years since their first
deployment
the defense minister says the country
owes them more than just gratitude
all the members their families
their communities an apology for the
racism and discrimination
they endured before during and long
after their service to canada the
effects of which
are still being filled a century after
the war ended
correcting the wrongs of the past begins
with acknowledging them
one city in the u.s is going a step
further evanston illinois has decided to
pay
reparations to black residents who faced
decades of discriminatory housing
policies
as jackson proskow reports it's the
beginning of a national movement in the
u.s
by giving back the opportunities that
were denied for so long
in the chicago suburb of evanston
segregation was quite literally drawn on
the map
it was a fast migration and evidence and
whites were panicking
what do we do about the black population
coming into evanston
as the city's black population grew in
the early 1900s
evanston began a racist practice called
redlining
forcing black residents to live in
certain neighborhoods
and making sure those areas remained
poor by discouraging
investment delois robinson's great
grandmother felt the effects
the redlining affect her and her husband
because
they were trying to open a business
in um in a well-established area of
evanston
but she was forced to just stay in one
certain area
to the point of she had to have the
restaurant
in her home discriminatory housing
policies were common in many american
cities up until the late 1950s
all these decades later evanston is
taking steps to atone
in an american first the local city
council approved reparations for those
who were directly
impacted by redlining and their
descendants
offering grants of up to 25 thousand
dollars which can be used for down
payments
home improvements or mortgage payments
i'm just grateful and thankful
that this is happening that
i'm here alive to see it happening we
get to benefit
for the hardship that they went through
evanston may just be the beginning
across the u.s
there's a national conversation about
reparations for slavery
systemic racism and overt discrimination
president joe biden has signaled an
openness well he supported a study of
reparations which i believe
is what's being discussed and studying
the continuing
impacts of slavery which is being
discussed it's complex
because there's little agreement about
what compensation should look like
evanston's reparations have been
criticized as little more than a housing
program
not a true reckoning it could possibly
be
the sullying of the true reparations
that the united states owes to us it is
however
a first step an attempt to try and
correct the wrongs of the past
by acknowledging the painful legacy that
still exists today
jackson prosko global news washington
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the bay of quinte
in belleville ontario
we want to see as many parts of this
country so please keep sending your
photos
to viewers at globalnational.com thank
you for watching donna friesen will be
back at the anchor desk tomorrow
and i'll see you next weekend have a
great week
you